a passel terrorists the day and tear
Dayton Ohio terrorists have you ever
heard about human zoos human zoos uh-huh
when you check out their DNA they might
be even more Mexican than a Mexican
exactly a recent issue you can you can
say that has is that national exercised
to approve racism and his manifesto he
called him invaders and he was actually
praising the Christ Church killer who
killed was at fifty some innocent
humanism and he was comparing the human
race to a garden that yes it has
different colors but that adds to the
beauty of it to go ahead and give
someone a hundred thousand dollars that
they can bring you anywhere where Jesus
said I am God worship me would you give
him a hundred thousand I they connect
him somehow to Islam BAM is the label
terrorist radical Islam they bring an
NSAID and even in America in nineteen
twenties to 1970s there were a lot of
states run eugenics with Islam that
Islam is a solution to the race problem
we actually worship the Kaaba or that or
the black stone you can end up in the
Hellfire you're out of Islam here at
Islam that kills that argument you need
blood blood sacrifice no need for that
original goodness now and is it true now
at the end that you're like a newborn
baby free of sin losing humanity to show
that you have more in line with the Eid
actually the victory of pure monotheism
exactly sort this
bismillah alhamdulillah assalamualaikum
greetings a peace and for those people
who are watching the people on the TV
they're excited maybe they missed this
year of going to out of fat or they're
there already and now some people are
confused and what's the wisdoms behind
it well we got imam out of fat here in
the studio we're gonna be talking about
the road to Mecca Hajj as a spiritual
journey assalamu alaikum how are you i'm
doulas good to have you on a program so
people some people are gonna be on out
of fire your name is out of fire yes
right how did you get that name now out
of AA because that's that tell us what
other fat is actually the word out of
fat is the name of the valley were at
least nowadays around two million people
will be staying in two million yeah in
the season of hajj two million people
who would be dedicating their time only
for asking God for forgiveness and that
makes the same looks like the day of
judgment hmm so that is the climax of
the Hajj experience so you're an imam
you're also someone who's you finished
from the islamic university of was hot
yes I got my bachelor's degree from
al-azhar university and then my masters
from the Divinity School of the
University of Chicago and right now I am
working on my dissertation for your PhD
yes
Oh mashallah Hajj fifth pillar of Islam
one is to testify that there's nothing
worthy of worship except the creator of
the heavens and earth there's no god but
the one God Allah Muhammad is the
messenger does automatically include all
the other messengers who came the same
message worshiping one God one God alone
a prayer establishing a direct
connection with your creator five times
a day minimum fasting during the month
of Ramadan giving the poor due text
charity but specifically now we're
talking about the pilgrimage people make
pilgrimage to Europe to Disneyworld this
world that world we're talking about the
pilgrimage to Mecca some people can't
make sense of it we're going to derive
some wisdoms for for it
yeah even thank you for the invitation
even for some Muslims they struggle with
the idea of making sense of Hajj itself
even you could see that in some
classical works that God commanded us to
do things that we can understand like
charity like prayers and we obeyed and
he wanted to see if we would obey when
he command us to do something that we do
not understand and they mentioned the
example of Hajj and this is absolutely
incorrect because Hajj is very very
meaningful and to understand where Hajj
is situated in the spiritual practices
of Islam you need to get to the roots of
Muslim spirituality islamic spirituality
is deeply rooted in knowing God and when
we know God there are few things that we
if we reflected on it will lead to all
of these spiritual practices that we
engage in so if we know God as the real
existent if we know God as the real
existent it will lead to that sense of
detachment and engagement what I mean by
these three words real existent is that
like me and you hundred years ago were
not here and in hundred years will not
be here so what kind of existence this
is the real one who exists is the
everlasting in the eternal and that is
only God so that is the core of Muslim
spirituality if we if for example it
basically means that a Muslim does not
allow himself or herself to be consumed
by the materialism outside why would you
allow yourself to be distracted by the
temporary from the eternal that is why
the spiritual system in Islam is
understood from that perspective we when
we understand God is the real existent
we detach ourselves for a while from the
dunya and we engage in the acts of
worship so in salah and Vicker we detach
from the world and we engage in in vicar
in fasting we detach from
desires of eating and drinking for a
while and we engage in more connection
with God in zakah we we detach from
parts of our money and we engage in
helping the poor and the needy and now
the climax of that detachment and
engagement comes with Hajj that's the
climax now exactly that's the top of the
top so that some people do not cannot
make sense of it now this is the climax
of of Muslim spirituality when you
understand it under the table under the
idea of engagement detachment and
engagement did all the profits that are
lost sent to guide humanity out of his
love did they all make this pilgrimage
to Hajj yeah many prophets did it too
how did the Hajj and and yes because
again it's the same it's not necessarily
the Kaaba
but it's this central idea of detaching
yourself from your community your
society your country and you're heading
for a different place for a sacred place
where you dedicate weeks or months for
absolute words you're answering the call
of a color hemella because I'm here
you're saying here I'm here at your
service my lord how would you translate
that yeah it lebesgue iike allahumma
labbayk means Oh Lord I come answering
your call
so and again this is the climax we we
answer God's call in the five daily
prayers but that is an easy answer but
now this answer for Hajj requires that
you leave your country your money your
family and everything behind you you
answered her call his call the bosses
call the president's called this call
that now you're answering your creator's
call exactly Allah the Almighty so this
is one way of making sense of Hajj in
other ways with knowing God we know God
through his attributes I like what you
have here is knowing when you know your
creator you have that yearned that
yearning feeling to meet your Creator
and so continue on there with and it's
Hajj Hodges is that yearning to go ahead
and answer the call into it to get as
close as you can to your creator knowing
that that by by obeying him living the
life that he wants you to live you're
gonna actually get to see him in the
next life
yeah I think the I want to place more
emphasis on the idea of going back to
the roots of Muslim spirituality yeah if
you really want to understand what hatch
is for so if you know God is the real
existent you will understand that Hajj
is the culmination of detachment and
engagement and if you get to know the
attributes of God like you will develop
that love for God because as a scholar
say why do we love anybody
we love anybody because of the
attributes of beauty majesty and
holiness these are the three reasons why
we love anyone beauty does not
necessarily mean physical beauty but
doing good to you is one aspect of
beauty we love people because of their
majestic qualities like absolute
knowledge like great knowledge great
power
we love to associate ourselves with
those people someone whose holy someone
who's perfect now God is the author of
all of these qualities so if you love
people because of beauty majesty and
power and holiness why don't you develop
that love for God and he is the source
of all of these types of qualities that
makes you love God so this is another
foundation for for Muslim spirituality
when you know God in this way you
develop that love and that love would
generate shout and yearning for God and
actually the Prophet prayed for this for
this spiritual state of yearning for God
he says Allah - Allah cachaça Allah like
I asked you to to give me to let me
experience this yearning for you I mean
right adora a madeira well i fitting it
in model basically without this show of
this passionate yearning i
I love to have it without being
stimulated by by a trial or tribulation
because some people some people could
want to leave and meet God because of a
problems they having but the Prophet is
asking for yearning that is absolutely
for who God is
so that yearning for God needs to be
quenched and and Hajj is a chance for
quenching our yearning of God and and
you can easily ask what is in Hajj that
would quench our yearning for God and
and all of the steps of Hajj would
really help us do that for Allah made
Hajj consists of shyah shyah or mean
signs or mean signs and one of these is
the Kaaba
so the Kaaba is one way of quenching our
yearning for God walking between safa
and marwah the Arafat and throwing the
pebbles these are signs and reminders of
God to experience God so we can talk
about these these four so one wants you
because in Islam we know that there's um
is not blind faith that you use the
faculties that Allah want Allah the
Creator heavens and earth gave you to
determine if is this Quran from him from
the Creator is the problem Hamid a
messenger from Allah now after you
determine that based on evidence and
proof and authenticity
now you submit yourself and now someone
can be like trying to make sense of all
this but do they need to go back to the
basics because once now if they're gonna
be questioning everything okay what's
the now it's good to know like okay law
said don't drink we don't drink but now
we see that every 10 seconds someone's
dying from alcohol now we can understand
this is our laws love he pushed away
this harm so some now we want to know
specifically for Hajj we want to derive
the wisdoms but not necessarily like if
someone is like having a crisis of faith
and they don't want to submit because
they kind of missed an it is that the
wrong mindset but I think as I said in
the beginning the reason why people may
not understand is because
they are missing the fermentation fat
dad so we're going back to the
foundation the foundation has to be
strong yes if someone is having doubts
because he does not understand why it is
seven not five I mean if it is three you
would ask the same question yeah but we
can talk about the practice itself this
is what we can question so now we're
trying to determine just and and
sometimes knowing these you submit
lovingly willingly obediently but now
you get to learn one of the wisdoms and
you're just like wow because the
companions of the prophet saw some at
that time they didn't know many of these
scientific discoveries that we know
today
they just submitted but now if you can
break down is there any significance to
so you talk about the attachment that's
one thing but now when you're at the
Kaaba is there any significance with the
number of times or with the blackstone
or with with Saha motto is there can you
talk about some of the is there anything
that we learn of the wisdoms yeah the
the valid question the valid question
when it comes to searching for the
wisdom when it comes to the Kaaba is to
ask why is the Kaaba why is the why why
do we do that circling around the Kaaba
are we worshiping the Kaaba so this is
the but to ask about why is it seven
times not five I think this is not it's
irrelevant why the Kaaba why they cover
the the Kaaba in the Quran in and our
tradition is considered to be as I said
God wants to quench people's yearning so
the Kaaba is that simple for for the for
the work of God God called the my house
so in the Quran it says we entrusted
Abraham and Ishmael saying Taher Bhatia
purify my house it milk I'm says it is
their association which makes people
have that yearning for God so that is a
symbol for what for God Himself the idea
of the Kaaba is is the first house of
God and this is something that quenched
your yearning for God and it is also the
place where God
answered Abraham and Ishmael ills
prayers to send the last prophet so we
honor this place because it marked the
fulfillment of the dua of Ibraheem and
Ismail so what are the next steps okay
so the person when they when they get to
the Hajj day they do the tour off so
they do that however and then after that
they do two Rakas drink from Zemzem and
then they do decide between safa and
marwah okay and if we're honoring that
wahid and monotheism and when we go
around the Kaaba and by the way this is
also a place that the mark that that
marks the victory of monotheism over
politics
that's a deep statement right there so
the the victory honoring the victory of
monotheism over polytheism because one
time at the time of the Prophet we had
around 300 and 360 idols around the
Kaaba now with with the mission of the
Prophet completed no idols around the
Kaaba so where we love this place
because it is it is symbolic for the
victory of the heat itself and
monotheism so we worship God inside the
Kaaba like you can pray Sunnah there and
out and around the Kaaba so it is a
place where you worship Allah there now
worshiping the Kaaba not worshiping the
place unfortunately a mosque it's like a
messages yeah but we honor it because it
is the ancient mosque and as I said it
marked the fulfillment of a lot of
Islamophobes and other people who are
just like victims of it we the victims
of the Islamophobia and then they get a
lot of misinformation out there and
people use this as a way to go ahead and
mislead people and they say no what kind
of monotheism when you guys are
worshipping not the Kaaba in this case
some people say the Kaaba but the black
stone what do you say to that again
we're going around the Kaaba and we're
saying labbayk allahumma labbayk were
were were communicating with God saying
O God will come to you answering your
call we're not addressing the carbon
anyway
but again as I said these are shy or
these are symbols yeah for experiencing
the love of God the black stone is
another symbol and it is even in in the
hadith it says it's implies 'as the
right hand of God
so when you touch it if you're entering
the palace of the king and and you're
you're making that commitment and you're
making that relationship with God it is
symbolic for that yeah then no matter
the ohan he he went and as he kissed it
what did he say
yeah he says I know that you do not harm
or benefit you cannot harm or benefit
exactly it's not worth worshiping it has
nothing to do with that I'm just doing
it because because the Prophet did it
before me I am copying the Prophet but
but I'm not worshiping you it has
nothing to do with worshiping if you
actually worship the Kaaba or that or
the black stone you can end up in the
Hellfire you're out of Islam here at
Islam that kills that argument continue
on continue so we were we're honoring
monotheism in the form of in the symbol
of the Kaaba because this is the word
the Quran use Shirah
that which is like sign or alum sup
between side between safa and marwah
walking between safa and marwah this is
around 400 mirrors between safa and
marwah and and and here we're
celebrating the heart of a lady the
heart of a lady
exactly this is Hodja she was originally
was looking for water for her baby
Ishmael at that time and she couldn't
find water and she did seven rounds
between safa and marwah yeah til she
find the water it's not a miracle right
there so there's two things you talking
about champion a woman right that
dispels a myth like Islam oppresses
women all this other nonsense out there
that anybody with any two cents that
looks into it see that this is just you
know far from the truth
but now you have were imitating in this
particular scenario a woman yes I always
say imagine if a man is looking for
water for his son would you go seven
times between safa and marwah or one
would be enough and say I didn't find
water yeah but she could not believe it
she could not believe [ __ ] that she can
not find water for the third
the baby that is why she kept looking
having trust in God and we're here
celebrating trust in God
so we honored monotheism and here we're
honoring one of the fruits of monotheism
which is trusting in God so this is what
again it is it is simples you're
dedicating your life for like in our
modern time for two weeks or three weeks
and having that intensive course in
spirituality by connecting with God and
then one of the marks and one of the
signs also is they are out of that time
the the out of FLE now you finish you
finish the the Tawaf you came there you
did the Sahara and now you go ahead and
now you're going next step is now so
people can follow along whenever who are
new to this thinking about accepting
Islam thinking about going to Hajj what
they can expect so the next one is know
that if we're going with order then you
trim then a you I mean
you cut the hair and then basically you
have a break if you're doing tomato and
then on the eighth day you go to Mina
and on the ninth day you go to Arafah so
we're talking about these major acts so
on out of a date this is the the the
most important act of worship during the
whole season of someone says why why
because on out of a day you see around
two million people in one spot Wow and
they have nothing to do but asking God
for forgiveness and asking God to draw
them closer to him Wow so it's like it's
it's as if it is the day of judgment are
they praying to any change to any dead
people in the ground at a party any
intermediate or they're just praying to
the Creator that have exactly directly
just wait long but with with the hope
that they will be forgiven yeah and that
is why scholars say the biggest sin on
that time and that time is when you
leave the Arafat Valley thinking that
God did not forgive you that's a big one
of the biggest change huh disparaging
exactly this is eerily God is the one
who for use
against God and God is the one who
forgives you need blood sacrifice no
need for that original goodness now and
is it true now at the end that you're
like a newborn baby free of sin yes this
is again this is the chance if you if
you do that sacrifice and you dedicate
that time for that journey you come back
as newly born spiritually yeah give us
some more that you cover in your in on
the road to Mecca some more the wisdoms
that you think are very powerful that we
can benefit from I think if we can
benefit from this and not just
religiously but also in our civil life
if you see the the scene on Arafat you
see as I said two million people all men
are dressing in the same way just two
pieces
there is no luxury there everyone is
equal
you can no differentiate between the
ruler and ruled deep between the rich
and the poor between Arabs and non-arabs
all differences are absent and all
people are equal if we become equal in
the prayer by putting our forehead on
the ground regardless of your color race
nationality or language again the climax
of that equality is in is in Hajj that
is why it affected Malcolm X so much
when he did his has I think it was in
1964 when he wrote that famous letter
and and he believed that there is hope
in America when he saw this this season
of Hajj and he said I was welcome dand
no one was judging me basically by by
how I look and by my color so has
experience gave him hope that racism
could could one day end with Islam that
Islam is a solution to the race problem
we're seeing a lot of it now we just had
we just had what are your thoughts just
saw
diverging a little bit but it's
connected to this because in in in our
country here in the America we just had
in El Paso
you had the manifesto of the person
shooter a gunman but he gunned down what
was it like 20 human beings and his
manifesto he called him invaders and he
was actually praising the Christ Church
killer who killed was at 50 some
innocent human yeah and this is based on
what the this is the original sin which
is that correct che that racism that
that I'm better right I'm better than
this person I'm better than he or she
that him my color of my skin nationality
so he went and gunned down these people
because of his racist so why should what
they call right supremacy or what not so
based on this recent issue you can you
can say that has is that National
exercise to approve racism this is what
America needs what exact was this
National exercise because you have
people from all parts of the world
coming from one place dressing the same
invoking the same God there is there are
no signs of differences between them so
you come like Malcolm X he came he saw
the yellow man Chinese man the redneck
whatever you want to call it all
different shapes and sizes and colors
rich poor and we need to get Donald
Trump and some other people to do her
job and the visa
sadly swatch Harley's watch or
appreciate that gathering that does no
different there is hope for everyone
shape because look the visa you have to
go through hoops and measures and
everything I mean they put you through
all sorts of restrictions to get a visa
I mean over there it's pretty simple
visa just declare what's in your nature
that there's nothing worthy of worship
we've said the crater that happens on
earth and and we all go back to the same
Adam and Eve this is also something
that's how you get into the Hajj right
say the Shahada and then accept it
understand it it's not II don't suppress
like you're fit your innate nature and
then this is the then you had another
one 24 hours later you had the Dayton
shooter you know you heard about him
right not even 24 hours later another
race racist went down and gunned down
other what was
like nine people or something they need
to get the Hajj they need to accept they
need to look into Islam yeah there there
is actually a very sad history of racism
even scientifically the idea of the Y
being superior species did you hear
about OTA Benga please share that with
us this is a very sad history and in in
the West have you ever heard about human
zoos human zoos uh-huh no I haven't sir
human zoos uh-huh
this is really when when racism had that
scientific justification so OTA Benga
and you can easily search him what a
Benga was epitome from Congo and he was
brought by an African missionary is an
American business and African missionary
he was brought to the u.s. because he
found out that his four inches I mean
four feet and two inches tall with
pointed teeth so he thought that this is
a good example at man and this is a good
example to illustrate evolution and he
was caged in a zoo what had been gay was
caged in a zoo and when he was I think
32 years he took his life because of
some depression he was going through so
the there is really sad and even in
America in nineteen twenties till 1970s
there were a lot of states run eugenics
that applied mandatory sterilization
that targeted 60,000 Americans most of
them are African Americans and and some
children are coming from poor families
that is our history it is only I think
in 2014 new Carolina was the first state
to compensate the victim
the alive victims of this practice and
they gave them $20,000 as a first
payment for that so we really have this
is deeply rooted problem it to deal with
this it has to be uprooted from grounds
it has to be uprooted and you have to
admit that you're coming you're
worshiping one God and that liberates
everybody and you have to believe
certainly and firmly that you're coming
from the same Adam and Eve so these two
if these two are not firm in our beliefs
there will be no change can you go back
and actually the day they did they did
tests on this when they checked peoples
lineage with was it with the DNA and
then so the person there's no someone
purely European exactly you could be
having your roots in Africa is that
you're having green so that paso shoot
that a paso terrorist the date and tear
dayton ohio terrorists these people they
are going and killing Mexicans and
trying to kill Muslims and other African
Americans they might have when you check
out their DNA they might be even more
Mexican than the Mexican exactly that is
scientific that's right right so what do
you think about this just to go off and
we'll come back to Hajj where what do
you think about this one as soon as
somebody is connected to somehow being a
Muslim even though it doesn't pray
doesn't fast doesn't go to Hajj maybe
has like a Muslim somewhat you know an
Arabic name was some name and now they
maybe they connect him somehow to Islam
BAM is the label terrorist radical Islam
bringing in but a lot of a lot of times
like in these people shooter you know
gunmen no name terrorists in front of
they don't use it what have you yeah and
no no religious identity they don't
connect him with a religion I'm sure I'm
a hundred percent you can connect
ninety-nine percent that you could
connect them and we don't blame
Christianity or anything but you can if
you wanted to make a case you can
probably see that his parents went to
church or his grandparents you can
somehow connect in the
be a Christian but we don't blame
Christianity what are your thoughts on
that yeah it seems that there is
deliberate intention to do so but it has
been so obvious that many people are
noticing it's so overt yeah people are
noticing even you would see non-muslim
commenting on the same exact observation
yeah that's a good thing you see you
have a lot of non-muslims not yet
Muslims were out there now speaking
about these double standards yeah so
back to Hajj now so we went off here
giving a live example of the race sysm
that's happening now and it's leading to
this terrorism that's happening on in
our home here in our backyard and Hajj
being what you're saying the eradication
give an example of Malcolm X to uproot
that that racism through Hajj there is
one verse in the Quran that really it's
it's something that every human being
would be proud of and this this is the
verse saying yeah you had in the
jalapeno cumin second one fellow people
we created you from a male and female
what you are now come show baba Baba
Lalita our tofu and we made you peoples
and tribes so that you get to recognize
each other in a Croma command Allah here
at Kaku the most honorable among you are
the more who have more piety more
righteousness so this is again equating
between all people mmm Messiah D has a
book called about the the unity of the
human race and he was comparing the
human race to a garden that yes it has
different colors but that adds to the
beauty of it so and he's talking about
the different levels of being relative
one part is is is the is the Adam
relation and and it is interesting that
the word human being in Arabic could be
translated in Arabic - Adam II which
means related to Adam so a human being
is someone who's related to Adam yeah so
so in in in the Muslim tradition you
have that deeply rooted someone was
making
funny note on when Obama wind the
American election and people will
celebrating this idea that we have a
black president and he said I looked
into the Egyptian history and I found
out that said that was was black and no
one noticed it no one noticed that his
his black and and because the problem
does not exist itself the problem itself
is not there so it's not about white
president or black president that was
never have never been a discussion it
has never been a question to or
something to wonder about yeah but he
said as I was reviewing the picture he
said he's coming from Upper Egypt he
looks black so we had a black president
before but it's it's out of question
it's not there it's irrelevant and this
is the power of Islam this is the power
of surrendering to the one God and the
power of recognizing your original roots
in a diamond and I'm however and Eve
because we're our brother we can say
we're all brothers in humanity exactly
that is one level the Adam II the Adam
relation yeah so so so we covered the
artifact all day you know making dua
supplication and when what goes on from
there after that one major one major
sign that remind that connects people
with God is is is the the jama'at which
is throwing the pebbles you threw it
against big pillar and this simple eyes
is your declaration that you're taking
the devil as your enemy so if you're
saying Lebec allahumma labbayk oh god I
come to you answering your call now we
were taking it to the next level and
taking the the devil as your enemy so it
is an exercise in commitment and during
the whole season of Hajj it's always
done with vicar vicar and remembrance of
God and praise of God penetrates through
all of the acts of Hajj and this is one
of so the the problem with people who
cannot make sense of Hajj is that they
look at the
which was themselves and they forget the
roots they forget the foundations and
they forget what is done in the hash
it's like someone looking at a Muslim
praying thinking that he's doing an
exercise no it's not an exercise all of
these movements are coupled with words
of praise for God and and meditation and
and same thing with Hajj when it comes
to data love there are words of praise
you're saying sigh there are words of
praise you're saying and out of it's all
about prayers and words of praise and so
on and then wrapping up what goes on
from there so you you you finished out
of fact you do the the gym around and
what else now closing up what else goes
on for the people to to get a better
visual what goes neck was finished some
of some of the steps are repeated some
of the steps are repeated you do toe off
again the federal twelve but these are
the major as to major these are the
major signs that you go through in Hajj
and how they connect you with your heart
we can we say proudly I mean this is
again the the six articles of faith in
Islam to belief in one and only one God
we you you repeated this so often
because that's the the core message the
belief in the Angels belief in the books
that were revealed to the messengers the
day of judgment paradise Hellfire and
the Kadir the the pre destiny God is
all-knowing of everything not ignorant
of anything this is the belief this is
the belief system of Islam this is the
same belief system of Jesus Moses
Abraham all of these they carried that
same court the law has had changed he
knows some specifics but there's the
same core message yes because the unity
of God leads to the unity of the message
if you believe in one universal God that
should lead to a universal message yeah
because that message is about who God is
what is life what is the afterlife and
these things are not subject to change
some people some people now okay so then
you have the the qurbani you talked up a
little bit about that and say some
people who have a misunderstanding say
you see you guys are sacrificing now
look we have the sacrifice of Jesus you
have sacrificed animals the pagans used
to do that to their gods and
you've heard this yeah you did okay and
how do you address this it's very simple
we're doing this to feed the poor and
the needy and when you help people in
need you get closer to God it has
nothing nothing to do with getting your
sins forgiven because we do not believe
in the original sin and for Jesus to die
for you that is not that is very
theologically problematic because for in
in Christian theology for that sacrifice
to be to make sense God has to die if it
is a human or animal sacrifice it
doesn't count
so can God die no so this is the this is
the the big problem it's not as easy as
people think so when you when they are
talking about Jesus as perfect sacrifice
that perfect sacrifice has to be God or
at least God man but it still it has God
in it and and no one could could
understand this idea that God is being
crucified for people's would you put up
a hundred thousand right now to say if
anybody can bring you again this is out
of the love we do it to have people to
think you know delivering this just pure
message of monotheism to go ahead and
give someone a hundred thousand dollars
that they can bring you anywhere where
Jesus said I'm God worship Me would you
give him hundred thousand I do so
because they're the many questions admit
that there is this idea does not occur
in the Bible itself the idea of I am God
worship me it's not there it's not where
they are clear unequivocal statement
where Jesus ever said that I am God
worship me and again when it comes to
some verses that that that many question
brothers would would interpret as
leading to the divinity of Jesus I I
would advise them to to understand these
terms in the way the Jews did because
you would have things like and they in
like in in some translation and they
worshipped Jesus but the idea of worship
Jesus is also worship that you would say
we would find equivalent terms in the
Old Testament and it's not about worship
like worshipping God yes this is a sign
of respect
sign of respect yes so you see all of
these interpretations but if you read
the
new testament with jewish lens you will
not reach the question theological
conclusion yeah not to go off topic but
yeah you're a hundred percent so you got
$100,000 challenge if someone can show
where Jesus and any authentic statement
said that I am God worship me you got a
hundred thousand coming from Imam had a
fact but you see in clear verses where
he's distinguish ease subordinate to God
that he's calling people saying he's
sent by God calling the people to only
worship the one God that he didn't he
wasn't all-knowing God is all-knowing
that he was born allegedly they say he
died God is not born doesn't died this
is common sense but it's a shame that
common sense isn't always common
practice so this is very clear so
wrapping up I wanted to just touch about
a couple more things so we kind of
clearly just in this summary of Hajj we
covered you know so many so many
beautiful wisdoms one thing that comes
to mind is uh because we have as an
ultimate proof the Quran is authenticity
the signs that are in there the
prophecies I mean just a believable
message then just looking at the the
life of prophet muhammad peace and
Buzz's be upon him examining his life no
one who sincere humble genuine would
walk away thinking otherwise then what
he called him people to believe in this
message that he was anything else than
what Allah claimed he was and hymns and
what he claimed to be genuine is here
you have to be that now along with other
signs one of them because we're talking
about Hajj
can you comment on Zemzem when when when
when when Hodja twenty went back and
forth now you have this water that
sprung the Zam Zam and to this day it's
still springing still gushing and then
you also had a Chinese scientists who
actually examined this this this water
have you read on that and how he
differentiated you know this water from
other water they did tests on it can you
comment comment on the on the zem zem no
I we're gonna put something I can they
can they can look at I'll put something
up but the idea that this Zamzam is is
still running for fourteen centuries
is a great miracle that we witness
that's amazing didn't the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him talked about
it being a cure or some sort also yeah
it's there is also a in in in our
tradition there is there is evidence
that this is a blessed yeah water that
could heal based your based on your
intention yeah we believe that the one
who heals is God but God put some means
to reach that healing and there are many
people who reports improvement so this
is kind of X and of Shiva he can give
through she how would the translation
healing for healing I mean there there
is personal witness to this person
experience from people who who got
healed yeah through exams am who got
their prayer answer during the Arafat
they never had children for years I know
someone was really really so you know
life stories I know someone someone
who's really known to me and he never
has had kids for decades tell us about
it and and then he went that day and he
made that door and then and then he
called his wife by the end of the Hajj
season and she gave him the good news
that she's pregnant Allah and it is it's
really amazing yeah III know true story
of a of a Muslim in Bosnia and they
wrote about him that he actually he was
written off by the doctors he had a
stage four tumor and he was pretty much
written off that he had several weeks to
live someone brought him the hadith of
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon the authentic hadith about the the
Zemzem and he went down to Amara and he
would just was drinking the Zam Zam Zam
Zam making positivism and he came back
did the test and he was cure so we
should also understand that were not
testing God yeah so if someone did this
and he does not see results it does not
mean there is a problem in this because
it's it's like the dates there are some
hadith about the dates to but it's again
it's putting your trust in God through
that means and God is the one who
answered the prayers and it could be
answered immediately
would be answered in a year it could be
answered it will be answered in God's
Way so we can also use it to test God's
answering that's all that's a real
important point
isn't there a verses we were talking
about in our in our closing up of the
sacrifice that the food goes to to the
poor it's not
isn't there an eye on the crime where
Allah is saying that it's not the blood
that reaches Allah but it's the it's the
piety it is the top one so so again this
is another another point that goes back
to your question about original sin it's
it's more about these acts are more to
show to show support for people that is
done sincerely for the sake of God not
for showing off yeah what's your opinion
now should you keep in that tradition
some people now here that are here in
the States
they say well there's poor people
involved in in in Ethiopia about this
smart whatever the case I'm just going
to send money [ __ ] can they send money
and still keep that tradition alive what
is it to do that to actually physically
do the qurbani here and some people say
why should I do it here there's no poor
people for me to give mmm how do you
answer that question if there are poor
people in America if they do not know
that they should check how does it work
one-third one-third one-third yes this
is this one but it does not have it has
to be three parts very hard one but it
doesn't have to be equal yeah so you can
have two pounds for yourself and this is
your part and the rest is for your
friends or and for the needy families so
it does not have it's not restricted
this is the should now but it is it is
Sunnah but what I am saying it does not
have to be one-third one-third one-third
yeah but it can be one part one part
three parts it does not have to be equal
parts okay so this is again to give more
chance for poor people to to benefit
from the sacrifice they can do here they
can do in in a country that they they
think they need the most
but to exclude
the place you're living in is not it's
not the right option to do yeah because
there are needy families and we have
many mosques that has food pantries and
they are serving hundreds and hundreds
of families Muslims and non-muslims yeah
but if they feel that there is more need
in some countries yes they can transfer
that via to them yeah is there a great
blessing and reward for keeping this
legacy alive for actually going through
the process in Italy actually that the
problem that people tend to compare
others with our life there are people
who can not find meat or food
I mean meat for months so it's this is
not luxury to them so yes this is a way
of feeding people yeah well just eat now
so you have eat after this now it's time
for the celebration talk to us a little
bit about to eat it's interesting that
it's it is when it comes to eat if you
look when it comes to I eat it's very
interesting to consider the timing we do
not have eat because of Hegira because
of a victory in a battle and these are
usually nations would pick their days of
variate around political achievements
and national victories but in Islam our
Aid is connected with your personal
spiritual growth after you finish
Ramadan you have a celebration after you
finish Hajj you have a celebration and
if this it's interesting to notice that
this celebration is run by the
remembrance and the vicar of God so so
the Eid is a reminder that any day you
get closer to God any day you get closer
to serving humans in the day of
celebration for you yeah this is
interesting because you have a lot of
Muslims who will forsake some of these
some of the ease and some of the
monotheistic traditions and they'll
wish someone Merry Christmas and they'll
get into some of these things that with
all due respect you have more in line
for the Christian really following Jesus
like you mentioned to celebrate the
victory of monotheism with the heed the
other heed with the with the victory of
you've put our humility some Abraham
willingness to sacrifice his son so
that's more in line with Christian the
true Christianity right but this concept
of of Jesus dying for your sins and you
know this goes in line with associating
partners with God with shidduch and then
they'll fall into these get a Christmas
tree and do things that even the Bible
doesn't sanction calls people who do
this pagans and other derogatory things
and this is just a point of you know
educating our brothers in humanity to
show that you have more in line with the
eat actually the victory of pure
monotheism exactly so so that is true
that's obviously true and also I take
this change I mean do you see that you
see that I'm you're a mom you're a
leader in the community you see a lot of
these things going on yeah I I see some
of these practices that some Muslims
would would fall into and it does not
mean it does not make sense even to some
questions some questions do not
celebrate it in this way many are
against their materialism against you
know we're doing these things if you
look to they have pagan roots exactly
yeah yeah even we're talking about pagan
even the word God because some people
say Allah they think that Allah is like
the moon god but Allah is a perfect word
for God because the word Allah does not
have does not have plural form
it's Allah you cannot say in Arabic
Allah has it's it's the one absolute God
yes this is what it means in Arabic so
it's absolutely monotheistic the word
God could be gods
it could have plural form the word God
comes also has its pagan roots it does
not come from the word good so same
thing here when it comes to looking at
the roots Islam is really deeply rooted
in this gray
meanings yeah Islam Islam is L AM Aslam
says love all mankind that's what we're
sharing this message for all of our
brothers and sisters and humanity you
got to learn a little bit about the Hajj
that deep victory or over public policy
ISM the victory of monotheism pure
monotheism and if you love your cradle
of God
you're gonna love Islam and we cleared
up some of those misconceptions talked
about the fifth pillar of Islam the Hajj
I want to thank you so much for sharing
some of those wisdoms with us and we
wish everybody a blessed Eid thank you
yeah so thank you so much no problem and
we hope wish you guys who again watching
this during the Eid and during this
blessed time that you go ahead and
continue to tune into the Deen show and
send we're sending our salams and we
give the Ummah biotic I'd remove water
Mubarak from me
and Imam Arafat and for our brothers and
sisters and humanity if they want to
visit you Sheikh they can visit you at
your mosque it is the door open or we
always encourage not your Muslims to
come and learn about and and they do we
have great relations with with
non-muslims with our Christian neighbors
yeah and if you're in the Chicago area
you can you can come go ahead and visit
a mosque or anywhere make that human
connection because you have so much so
much negative false propaganda out there
and the only way to eradicate much of
this fear and ignorance is to education
that's what we're humbly trying to do
educate you on this beautiful way of
life that brings peace contentment
solace to the hearts continue to tune in
subscribe if you haven't already leave
us your takeaways in the comments below
we'll see you next time inshallah God
willing here on the Deen show please be
with you
as-salam-o-alaikum